[Music]  find out what your council has done for  you we're making mid Suffolk a better  place for everyone we're investing  millions in our community facilities  we're building more affordable homes  than before we're keeping our streets  clean tidy and safe we're proud that mid  Suffolk has been voted on the top places  to live in the UK for the first time in  30 years we're building council houses  again we've brought empty properties  back into use created accessible homes  and tackled homelessness community  groups in Suffern do some amazing work  and help thousands of people we've given  them funding to make that possible it's  helping to make mid Suffolk a stronger  community making sure the right kind of  homes are built in the right places is  one of our most important jobs and we've  helped our communities to take control  we're also regenerating key areas to  boost our economy  we are mid Suffolk District Council we  are your Council find out what we've  done for you